[Music]
okay
did you guys see this really hilarious
thing that happened in the news with
gavin newsom
yes yes yes okay so this fool which by
the way he's
fool's gone wild he's the governor of
the state he's the governor of
california
and trying to shut [ __ ] down
exactly i can't believe he told people
to
eat in between is that what we're doing
oh no no no
that's hilarious
like that was on his website dude he was
like
when you have thanksgiving feast make
sure your family does this [ __ ]
like [ __ ] crazy man it's incredible
dude this one's crazy yeah
that's our government the idea that that
you're about to take a bite and then
corona is like
and then you put the mass back on it's
like oh okay
that's so good all right so gavin newsom
he has been like the biggest preacher of
like
you better stay at home you better not
be gathering with people you better not
be
really close to people like shoulder to
shoulder you better not be touching
people you better be wearing your mask
all the time right he's like
keep it under ten etc yeah less than 10
people in a in a in less than three
households
in a gathering and all that [ __ ] right
man we're all gonna get it
well hold on so so or we probably had it
all
recently this whole he got caught dining
with the party of guests
and he was not following his own
coronavirus protocols
and he's just one big gigantic hypocrite
he wasn't chewing and putting his mask
on
nope no mess damn and he was at french
laundry
yeah so he was at french london really
nice round in new york three
michelin star restaurant in napa valley
oh
it's a thousand dollars a plate
basically yes three michelin star that's
wild
star i don't even know what that means
i'm not that high class i don't even
exist in the world
it's the highest rating that a
restaurant could get you know the
michelin tire
bar bart dines at that huh [ __ ] yeah
so like the michelin star it's a rating
for restaurants for like globally
and then i think what a three star means
is that that restaurant is supposedly so
good
that it's worth getting a plane ticket
to go there and then returning home
so three star is the highest yeah even
the scale like one out of three is
like getting one star is already a huge
deal even though it sounds like it's one
out of three it's like just to be able
to
get
one star that's a people spend 30 years
trying to perfect their restaurant
trust that [ __ ] though cause i ate at
three michelin star raid uh rated places
and they all [ __ ] suck that's kind of
nasty
yeah yeah how many places did you try
three two we tried three of them two in
five
france and one in vegas here i mean no
offense
they paid for those stars all that
cuisine sucks
it sucked i said no fast someone out for
those stars
all politics probably oh for sure
guarantee
yeah so owe me 100 racks give you three
michelin i don't believe that [ __ ]
anymore
but yeah so these are the photos that
were taken of gavin
and his wife at the french laundry
restaurant
she got a big zero on her dress no it's
this box
it's a watermark
[Laughter]
yeah and then this is the other photo so
as you can see
it looks like they're indoors oh yeah oh
yeah
as if like not one person's wearing a
mask there's who took these [ __ ]
photos too some paparazzi asked me well
it was this lady that was dining there
and she was like
wait is that gavin the one that's been
giving us the rule
yeah and then so and then she'll she is
that more than 10 though let's count
let me see let's count well they don't
have mascot that's for sure four
five six seven eight nine ten okay well
he's following the ten group
i think there's maybe one one person
went to the bathroom i think that's
[Music]
once it goes from 10 to 11. yeah you're
talking about our corona situation
11 maybe 12. oh you're getting corona
i heard there was once it says in the
article oh
sorry it's 12 people yeah 12 guests
none of them were wearing masks that's a
200 more chance of getting corona
right there yep as soon as you add every
person
that's [ __ ] crazy so anyway so then
this lady
who wants to remain anonymous she was
saying that she even asked a waitress to
confirm like is that
governor gavin knew something and she
was like yeah that's him i'm a tale
yeah so then she started taking pictures
and then she said
a lot of money for those pictures oh
yeah oh for sure oh so here's another
photo of the restaurant
so they're saying that like this
restaurant is
is pretty much like outdoors because
they have these gigantic sliding doors
so it lets in a breeze and the gym's
outdoors then
[ __ ] you know my whole gym's
outdoors
isn't it funny how they call this [ __ ]
outdoors but then now people are just
building
tents which is just indoors it's
hilarious tents with sides
yeah it's to the corona code it's like
you can't eat inside unless the inside
is outside yeah i'm so confused by that
there's walls in the tent there's no air
flow what the [ __ ] are you doing
anyway but here i guess it's better than
completely enclosed
and so anyway so then when gavin newsom
got caught
he ended up apologizing
and i'm gonna play his apology for you
guys hell yeah
i want to see politicians get spanked me
too every time they [ __ ] up
you got some spanking i know hey maybe
big boy can do it
all right here we go i find it hilarious
by the way how he's like
i [ __ ] up here yeah yeah what does he
do the politicians speak in a few weeks
to go to a friend's 50th birthday uh my
wife
and i friend that i've known for almost
20 years and
uh and a friend that and put a lot of
time and energy into his 50th birthday
it was in napa which was in the orange
status relatively loose compared to some
other counties
uh it was to be an outdoor uh
restaurant and we started the well the
program
started at four o'clock it was one of
those early reservations i got there
it's late at fourth so much bass doing
yeah as soon as i sat down at
the larger table i realized it was a
little larger group
uh than i had anticipated uh and i made
his friend
mistake instead of sitting down
i should have stood up and
walked back got in my car and drove back
to
my house chose to sit there with my
wife and a number of other couples that
were outside the household
i decided to sit with these criminals
guidelines et cetera et cetera but the
spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time uh
was contradicted and i got to own that
and so i want to apologize to you
uh because he's smiling so hard preach
makes you want to slap
him not just preach and not practice and
i've done my best to do that
it seems so sarcastic you know like like
he like he wants you to beat the [ __ ]
out of him
the clip went a little longer horrible
the next thing he says is i'm not i'm i
am a human it's like
oh yeah he does say that too really he's
like you know we're human we're all
human
we make mistakes and all this other [ __ ]
crazy i just love that he threw his
friend
under the [ __ ] bus and he's like he's
like they're with other people i was
uncomfortable
i sat there we i ordered some wine i had
a we had a four course meal i had some
dessert
i was very uncomfortable no but check it
out so that said that no no but
it might as well happen who took the
photos and who witnessed him
there right she was like huh he said
that as soon as he sat down he felt
uncomfortable
but funny thing is he did not look
uncomfortable until
he started to leave when everyone was
staring at him that is the moment
where he was noticeably uncomfortable
but the entire time he was [ __ ]
chilling with his friends
but i hope to god this ends the [ __ ]
politician era
and we have way better leaders or people
that are supposed to be in leadership
positions because [ __ ] these guys
these guys are [ __ ] annoying i know
they've had their run
yeah of shitty we should just try like
normal fools that'll go up and be like
yeah i [ __ ] ate with my friends
so what
he's like yeah he's like when i made
these rules i didn't know they wouldn't
be fun at all
i'm trying to save you guys yeah but
[ __ ] man i don't know how to do it
so hard to stick to these rules these
those are hard dude and then like the
most
the most like annoying thing too is that
california is now 94 like 94
of california is going into the purple
tier
again which is like the worst where's
the other six percent
uh like the other counties the areas
that are burning and [ __ ]
hey steve you know stats right i saw the
mayor
just post um there's a corona death for
every minute of the day not like that's
60 minutes
hell no times sometimes 24 hours i'm
like
like 2 400 people are dying the day of
corona is that just
that can't be true because the number
just hit 250
000 for deaths of corona but
that means that it should be like half a
million by now well because it's not
a minute of every hour of every day for
the entire year it's just what it is
right now
yeah he's saying it right because the
rate is the reason now
it does sound right a
like they came out with the cdc like
yeah the
no the deaths have gone up significantly
super duper high right now has 18 000
deaths
yeah twenty thousand has a and then over
a million cases
but over eighteen thousand deaths so
that's dude that's why i yeah
god when you look at that's
percentage-wise i mean
uh it's still small small as [ __ ] so
but yeah should everyone still be
careful and [ __ ] of course i mean
percentages are a weird thing to look at
though right if you say
let's say only one percent of the entire
world were able to die that's still like
a few million people right so like it's
it
it's hard to say things in percentages
when it's 70 but it's so
it's so great compared to what it was
looking like in february when people
were talking about 10
death rates oh yeah yeah it's because of
therapeutics and the way they handle in
hospital better
also i think the big thing uh especially
over the summer was that the hospitals
weren't being as overwhelmed and
that's the biggest thing right they got
time to stockpile all those yeah they're
not really worried about let's say
100 of people are going to get sick
that's not really the problem the
problem is
if they all get sick right now yeah then
nobody can get in the hospital right
they all get sick within three years
then it's spread out and then let's say
the hospital is always being filled up
but not
past capacity then the hospitals can
make a lot of money over the years
so that they can survive that's why new
york had that had that the mass graves
the [ __ ] refrigerated trucks as of
right now
as of today oh no wait november 18th
there were
on november 18th for the whole united
states there were 1 1923 deaths
today yesterday yesterday for one day
yeah
no the day almost 2 000 people died
yesterday
damn in the whole country yeah it's a
lot i mean 911 was 3 000 people
yeah have you uh tried going to any
indoor dining yet
it it feels funny because i was in
orange county i was looking for french
laundry
no i went to orange county and orange
county is much more loose
uh and then i went to pick up some food
and it's really funny because you see
people lined up outside the restaurant
everyone has a mask on
but when you go in the restaurant no one
has a mask on so it seems like the
operators now you have the mask on the
outside but then you don't have one
inside
no it was like a tightly packed
vietnamese restaurant
it was weird i love the clear tents
outside now where it's all zip up
denny's and [ __ ] it's whole it's
hilarious they're like
because their their customer base is all
old people too so they're like we got to
protect them
from the weather but now it's you don't
have any airflow
it's so good yeah well business has got
to stay open though too so they're just
doing whatever
they can i think you're like if you're
gonna write something following the
rules yeah you tell me some stupid ass
rules i'm gonna follow
those rules i know because the
restaurants are like one of the biggest
hits
of like the whole economy like a lot of
people are saying
the restaurant industry is not going to
survive this [ __ ] especially in new york
dude
i heard like fast food though has been
doing really well anything with the
driver
right what's the other there's one thing
there's stocks been up i seen like a
little thing mcdonald's went up you know
you guys see this one state actually
where restaurants are doing better than
normal
like every state the restaurant business
is down but idaho
yeah restaurant business is higher than
normal why
they don't know why just idaho i don't
know all right
[Music]
you